[Musique]
bienvenue bienvenue à toutes et tous
pour l'interview de capharnaüm alors que
nous rejoignent en ce moment même les
deux interprètes de ce film signé nadine
labaki qui est là avec nous bonjour
nadine merci infiniment d'être d'être là
avec nous avec ce film très fort qui a
secoué hier soir les festivaliers à vos
côtés donc le jeune shaheen
elle a leur a fait un bon jour zain
bienvenus bienvenue à cannes
yordanos chief héros bonjour yordanos
merci d'être là avec nous et votre
producteur et compositeur khaled
mouzanar bonjour à l'aide
bonjour bonjour bienvenue j'aimerais
revenir sur cette projection d'hier
parce que c'est une projection où les
larmes coulaient sur reçues sur les yeux
de vos spectateurs
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti vous à
ce moment là vous avez senti que la
salle et était véritablement conquise
par votre film comment ça s'est passé
vers maurice était très c'était très
émouvant c'était un moment inattendu et
inespéré
et j'étais surtout heureuse de voir les
acteurs comme ça c'est un moment
njawe je pense qu est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'il a ressenti le petit zain qu'est ce
qu'il a ressenti au moment de cette
projection à la fin de cette projection
est ce qu'il peut nous demander
[Applaudissements]
il dit qu'il a été complètement choqué
c'est la première fois pratique et izia
cannes il avait vu le film c'est la
première fois qu'il va le film en entier
alors comment il l'a trouvé comment at
[Applaudissements]
il dit c'était magnifique la moitié de
la salle était en train de pleurer c'est
vrai alors qu à vos côtés aussi yards à
9,6 féraud qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous
avez ressenti vous yordanos en voyant le
film tire match est un acte à celle à
long terme absoute à travers nos fils
l'anneau raté n'est ce pas là elle dit
elle est très heureuse parce que pour
elle ce n'est pas un film c'est sa vie
c'est sa vie parce que sa vie aussi
rejoint l'histoire de ce film c'était le
quelle était la volonté de départ parce
que cette idée d'un enfant qui fait un
procès à ses parents pour lui avoir
donné la vie est une idée très très
fortes qu'elles s'étaient aussi surtout
j'imagine l'envi de de mettre en scène
un enfant comme à in une femme comme
comme jordan aux comment comment tout ça
a démarré dans votre tête nadine labaki
tout a démarré je pense quand on d'abord
quand je j'ai commencé à réfléchir au
prochain film ça découle toujours d'un
thème dans certains thèmes qui m'obsède
obsession du moment le questionnement du
moment et donc il y avait ces thèmes-là
qui revenait souvent l'enfance
maltraitée là le problème
des immigrés les travailleurs migrants
au liban et dans la région en général la
notion des frontières la notion d enfin
ces enfants qui sont pas déclarés à la
naissance là la nécessité d'avoir un
papier pour prouver qu'on existe ce sont
des thèmes qui ça fait quand même un
bouton que ça me ça me travaille et donc
j'ai voulu un peu à travers le regard de
cet enfant
au départ c'était j'avais besoin de
faire beaucoup de recherches pouvoir
parler réellement de ces de ces
problèmes là et donc est au bout de ses
recherches
l'idée a découlé d'une manière très
naturelle c'est à force d'entendre ses
enfants s'expriment et on a été dans
beaucoup d'endroits très très très
problématique au liban on a visité
beaucoup de prison de deux mineurs
descendez de détention de mineurs les
associations qui accueillent ces enfants
en difficulté et c'est à force de
d'écouter ses enfants et de d'entendre
leurs réponses à ces questions qui
revenait souvent que finalement cette
idée de parler d'un enfant qui va
intenter un procès s'est imposé de
manière très naturelle
c'est des enfants qui la plupart du
temps quand on leur pose la question
êtes vous heureux d'être là te dire je
suis pas heureux d'être là pourquoi
m'avoir donné la vie si vous ne si vous
n'allez pas me mais si vous n'allez pas
me donner le fin mai mais moindres mais
mes moindres mes droits les plus
élémentaires besoin mais mes droits et
besoins les plus élémentaires
effectivement on sent une forme de
révolte aussi quand je vous entends la
nadine labaki je pense que vous apportez
vous avez pris cette révolte des enfants
comment on trouve un enfant comme ça
parce que c'est aussi cet enfant là bien
particulièrement zain zaid al harra fait
à qui est un qui est incroyable de
ventre votre caméra vous lui avez fait
vivre j'imagine des choses bien
particulière comment on trouve ce petit
zain saad du vous aider aussi quand vous
l'avez trouvée non oui d'abord ce le cas
ci est assez fait de manière très
sauvage carrément un casting sauvage
personnes des acteurs ne jouent dans le
film ils sont ce qu'ils sont dans la
galère
ils jouent à peu près leur propre rôle
évidemment je me suis adapté à leur
vérité a eu et j'ai dévié un peu ma
fiction qui était bien écrite c'était un
scénario bien écrit mais qui a dévié
vers la vérité de ces personnages qui
dans la vie vivent des choses très
similaires comme gold annonce vient de
dire ce n'est pas un film pour elle
c'est sa vie qu'elle raconte pascal ce
fait elle même arrêté aussi elle a
failli être expulsé c'est ça oui c'est à
dire que il s'est passé des choses comme
ça incroyable durant le tournage
une annonce dans la vie au moment où on
l'a rencontré n'avait pas de papiers
donc elle vivait de manière illégale
dans le pays
donc on a commencé à tourner pour parler
de son histoire pour parler de la vérité
de ce qu'elle vit au quotidien et au
moment où d'oran l'histoire dans le film
elle s'est fait arrêté le lendemain de
son arrestation dans la chine s'est
réellement fait arrêter dans la vie et
non seulement ça y est une autre
histoire un peu je ne sais pas pourquoi
il ya des choses positives le petit
enfant aussi exactement c'est avec ça
avec sa mère
c'est incroyable ce puits temps fort
justement je leur ai posé la question à
votre producteur aussi parce que si
c'est une dimension as a dû être très
très difficile de tourner avec les
enfants dans ces conditions là il ya 500
heures de rush je crois plus de 500
heures de rush presque six mois de
tournage
un an et demi de post production c'était
une aventure folle que si on ne sentait
pas tout ce qu'on était porté par
quelque chose de plus grand que nous
mêmes
personne n'aurait tenu jusqu'au bout
larissa les équipes travailler 24 heures
tout le monde a donné pour pour une idée
en fait c'est la vie de ces gens là on
savait tous qu'on voulait les les porter
à l'écran avec notre notre âme et notre
notre notre volonté suprême
il y avait quelque chose de plus grand
que nous et bah oui on passait notre
temps dans les prisons ont passé
longtemps à des gens qui rentraient en
prison on devait le faire on a passé
presque trois semaines sur notre actrice
principale
les parents de 2,2 du du petit gars du
petit garçon dans le village sont fait
arrêter
section phare été arrêtés alors qu'ils
sont ils ont passé un mois en prison
aussi donc on attend dans le tarn a dû
élever le bébé chez nous à la maison
pendant pendant le tournage est donc
vécue chez la réalisatrice et la
directrice de casting en fait yonath
dans la vie est une fille c'est ça parce
qu'au début quand je le vois je pense
que c'est une petite fille - certitude à
la salle est d'accord l'appel trésor
trésor quand elle s'est retrouvée sans
parents dans la
avec qui j'ai la directrice de
magnifiques soient quel rayon de soleil
dans ce film comment s'est passé le
tournage pour zain est ce que vous
pouvez lui poser la question comment il
a vécu ce tournage est ce que c'était
dur difficile qu'est ce que ça lui a
comment il a travaillé a dit que j'étais
gâté je ne l'étais chien pas oui on a le
tournage ah oui c'est ça mais est-ce
qu'il veut devenir acteur d'ailleurs ce
plat traditionnel va lui arriver
maintenant on peut lui poser la question
il veut devenir acteur quel peut être
son avenir justement à ce garçon là bas
c'est une grande question
zen et un réfugié syrien et vit dans une
situation très très difficile au liban
comme tous les réfugiés à travers le
monde
maintenant il ya une très grande
possibilité qu'ils soient accueillis
dans en norvège avec la famille là où il
va pouvoir peut-être aller à l'école
comme tous les enfants de la terre où
ses parents pourront peut-être avoir un
boulot on ne sait pas encore l'avenir
est un peu
incertain mais en tout cas
en tout cas j'espère je ne sais pas que
à travers ce que ce film puisse lui
offrir peut être un autre horizon c'est
une autre possibilité
ce qu'il ya c'est fou quand je vous
entends d'un dîner là bas qui sait que
lui par de partir en suède enfin moment
donné dans le film c'est ça il doit
partir surtout par les dalles norvège on
a l'impression qu'ils aient une
imbrication incroyable entre votre film
est la réalité
mais il s'est passé des choses mais inde
et indéfinie sans fin on n'arrivait pas
à les aléas les expliquer
comme l'histoire de ces gens qui se
retrouvent pendant le tournage
exactement au même moment où dans le
film l ess en mer dans la vie elle est
sans mère et avait plein de choses même
lame la manière dont tous les
personnages du film se sont exprimés
souvent ils parlaient de leur vie et on
était toujours entre défense demande et
on était nous mêmes un peu perdu entre
la fiction et la réalité quand soir à 2
me regarde dans la dans le tribunal et
qu'elle me dit en face ce qu'elle pense
et ce que je pense d'elle
ce n'est pas soit dans le film qui
s'exprime c'est qu'un seul dans la vie
son sac à ces cas où seules ses lacets
la femme dans la vie qui s'exprime
voulez-vous me crachent à la figure ce
qu'elle pense vraiment de mon jugement
envers l est
de ce qu'elle vit au quotidien et donc
et donc il ya tout on était toujours
comme ça en train de jongler entre
fiction et réalité va changer vous ça va
vous changer vous complètement changé ça
m'a transformé je suis une autre
personne depuis que je fais ce film
depuis que j'ai commencé l'aventuré sur
ce film je pense que ça a changé tout le
monde sur le film parce que parce que ce
n'est pas juste un film on était dans la
vérité de deux de ces histoires-là de
ces situations là les prisons sont des
vrais prison les on est on est intervenu
le le moins possible dans la vérité de
ce que vous jouez oui le moins possible
mais vraiment quand on avait besoin pour
la fiction de dévier l'histoire un peu
ou de remettre un petit bout de
découvrir un petit truc mais on a essayé
d'intervenir le moins possible parce que
j'avais besoin de croire moi même en
tant que réalisatrice à cette histoire
là et
merci mais voilà merci beaucoup nadine
labaki merci pour ce film bravo zayd
bravo yordanos bravo pour votre film
bravo également à vous khaled mouzanar
j'imagine que ça doit être quelque chose
de produire un film comme celui-là merci
encore n'espère puisque ça a peu changé
la vie de ses interprètes ça a changé la
vôtre on espère que ça changera au moins
le regard des spectateurs qui verront ce
film sur ses enfants sur ces
situations-là capharnaüm donc en
compétition officielle